and see if the marriage had been
uh recorded
and and just make that change based on
the information received in the portal
but if someone wanted to register to
vote
this would still require them to go
through the the process of filling out
at least an online application and then
processing the information through the
supervisor of the checklist who would
check our four things identity
citizenship domicile and
we'll go from from there
the third part is relative to recount
fees
um many in the states don't have a
recount fee
uh for a certain uh percentage
difference between
uh the different candidates this would
institute that
at a quarter of a percent so that uh a
candidate that was uh very close
uh within a uh i believe a quarter of a
percent is what i put in the bill
but then it does um go in for those
between
that quarter of a percent and three
percent
and raises the fees uh they are still
very very reasonable um for what is
uh required there is a big jump in the
statute right now
when you get to three percent which uh
requires that you pay the full cost of
the recount
um and this kind of short you know
narrows that gap between the two percent
and the three percent
uh but still like i say
they are still very very reasonable
uh part number four itemized statements
still
uh filed by political candidates and
parties
i know you've got legislation that you
pass through that
that changes part of the statute but
not this particular section right now
the biggest problem comes when a
candidate
uses a facsimile machine to send in
their financials is that depending upon
the quality that they choose in the
facts only machine
and other that when they send in these
financial statements
they are often unreadable
so this puts the
requirement that the candidate is
responsible to make sure
that that information is legible
and that if the secretary of state's
office finds that it is not legible
for the candidate to refile that
information and provide that legible
copy
i can expand on that if somebody has
questions later
the fifth part is actually not a part
that i sponsored but
one of the other senators and it has to
do with
uh locations that aren't operating
on a yearly calendar but
fiscal calendar that starts possibly in
in july the 1st and
allows them to continue to spend if
their meeting
is not held by july the 1st
so that they have the same advantages
that
the communities that have uh their
year starting in january the first
as all of you know you represent the
counties
and there is either tax and
participation notes
but they are still allowed the various
towns are allowed to spend money
based on the rules between that period
of january the first and when the
the budget is approved at town meetings
or even at the county level that
at the county which this uh doesn't uh
really address
uh but i'm happy to answer any question
that you've got
i tried to make it short enough that i
wouldn't be a burden on you
thank you questions from committee
members
senator gray i want us to the last part
the last section in regards to the
fiscal years
first question i guessed that the intent
was to deal with
approved budgets that dealt with more
than one
calendar year right the fiscal year goes
to two years rather than the prior year
correct
again i i'm going to speak from what
i understood uh senator khan to uh
uh his intent on this but
in durham coven what we did is we passed
legislation that
the towns could move their town meeting
uh to a different time
and if uh right now in the law the only
ones that can
use uh the spending provisions uh that
are in the law right now
to spend money between the start of the
fiscal the start of the calendar year
and their town meeting
um are towns that that operate that way
but if a town has a july first start
fiscal year
and they moved their town meeting into
july
which would have been authorized by the
executive order
then there was a problem with them
spending money
between july 1st and the authorization
of their town meeting
and this legislation uh
would give them that opportunity uh
should their town meeting for any reason
be delayed
and still retain uh the provisions that
the
normal towns that have a calendar your
budget
would be thank you senator i i did
understand that i guess i should have
been more specific my question relates
to
line five
uh in regards to the change from prior
years
to prior multiple years and so my
question
is if indeed what we're talking about
is a fiscal year isn't that what it
should say
because arguably prior years
could be any year
if i and maybe there's somebody there
who's a better english person than
i am but it seems to me that that
creates a plural
uh choice of previous years
um again the intent of okay
senator khan you'd have to speak to him
uh but
the the way i understand this is
the immediately prior year based on that
budget
and because the ones that start on july
1st have two calendar years i suspect
that's why it was made plural
however i think it creates another
problem so
that that is has been pointed out to me
and i just wanted to raise it uh and
care as as i often point out to people i
are an engineer
you know we're gonna have the numbers
not with the letters and the in the uh
grammar
so i'll defer to anyone else
all right um let's go through this
committee i
sort of can't believe we don't have any
questions here let's go through it
um by section part one
i'm dealing with the disqualification of
certain
persons in regards to being behind the
guardrail and ballots
questions from persons
i have a quick question madam chair all
right representative terozian and lob go
ahead
thank you thank you uh senator great for
taking the question
so just to clarify and it looks pretty
straightforward this only affects
say the town moderator or any other
election official who's on the ballot
for that particular election to be there
in the area of commonwealth so it
doesn't preclude them from being there
during the process of people coming in
to vote like they currently do
right there are many duties which need
to be performed
at the close of the election the
prohibition against
them touching a voted ballot
is still there that they will not be
involved in the counting
of their race but as many of you know
the verification of the checklist is
another thing that has to happen
uh there's other duties uh just cleaning
up the polling place remember we've got
all those postings inside the
uh voting boats that need to be cleaned
up the pencils the
you know in some communities they
actually uh disassemble the voting
booths and things to get
the room ready for a function that may
happen the next day
so uh again there's there's all kinds of
other things in the moderator
or the moderator's designee can
assign them to other duties
remember that in a lot of these
locations up north
it is very difficult to get enough
people to work the election
and especially qualified people and
that's one of the reasons why
i believe that this was passed in the
past
but because of legislative process
the the two statues have diverged a
little bit
this brings them back in line with each
other
thank you but
senator gray i have a question 658
following up on what you said
a 658-24 is a disqualification
as to handling the ballot
and counting the ballots
section 2 659-58 would appear
to be much broader in that
the person's designated
which would be we're adding a moderator
um or any election official
cannot be in the area designated for the
handling of marked ballots so that's
significantly broader than
not touching so in
for and i've got to relate to my
community because that's what i know
best
uh we have used a gymnasium
and everything occurs
in that one large area uh
the guard rail is set up and but once
you go to stand to take your ballot the
tables are there for you to mark the
ballot the booze
the absentee ballots are being processed
the food table the all-important food
table
is behind that guardrail at the end of
the room
and then the ballot counting devices are
at the end of the room
so if i restrict the moderator
who or election official from being
in that area
is it i could have a moderator so the
idea is i have a moderator on the ballot
but they're on
for a different office they're it's not
an election official
so now they can't be in my community
pretty much anywhere near anything
i have an elected moderator who can't
essentially do what he's been elected to
do right
well this would change that this would
say that they can be within
those guard rails and that's part of the
difference between
658-24 as it is now enacted and 659.58
as it is now enacted is that those two
statutes don't agree about whether the
person can be
in the area not in the area this
would combine those two statutes
together and say yes
you can be within the guard rails but
you can't be
you know any place right you know right
next to where they're
they're counting the votes or be
involved in the counting of the votes
and you could perform other duties
within that area
so like in your community when they are
counting the checklist to see how many
new voters how many
changes to republicans or democrats and
changes back
during the primaries all of those
functions have to be performed by
somebody
and an election official who was on the
ballot
not only for their elected position but
for some other position
could be in the area performing those
other duties
um you know so yes they would be able to
get to the food table
further questions hands anybody in lob
representative bergeron thank you thank
you madam chair um
this somewhat follows up on
representative griffin's line of
questioning
our new hampshire constitution says that
the
moderator uh in the presence of
selectmen
shall sort and count the said votes and
make a
public declaration thereof and this
statute seems to be saying well no you
can't
sort and count the votes
do you see a conflict in that is this
law in conflict with our constitution
uh i don't believe so uh i'm
normally the secretary of state is on
these and i don't know whether he's
signed up
as a speaker or not uh but um
there will be a uh
the moderator's designee or an assistant
moderator or whatever you want to call
them
uh who would be uh taking care of those
uh
functions of sorting a lot of times
when we talk about things like that we
may say the moderator but we also mean
the moderator's designee
and i believe that through all those
things
that we would meet the constitutional
test um
and i would be happy to defer to the
secretary of state's office
on that you know
i i don't have a problem with the uh the
moderator announcing the results because
those are also certified by the
uh town clerk or the award clerk
um and the uh selectmen
um but again as to touching those
voted ballots um that would not be
appropriate
and i believe that it would be covered
the constitutional part of it would be
covered by the moderator
uh selecting a designee to do those
functions
deputies scanlan is on as an attendee
i'll ask to hear from him after we
finish going through the sections for
committee members
any other questions for committee
members at this point on
section part two of this bill
i'm not seeing any hands i'm gonna move
on
to part three is the recount fees
anybody have any questions
for senator gray on part three
anybody in lob all right yeah man you
have a question
part two we take questions on that
yeah i'm sorry i thought i said i oh i
skipped that part two go ahead
representative terezian
thank you uh found chairman thank you
again senator
question um
is there a fiscal note or any uh idea
what it would cost to set
up this uh information portal
and i have a follow-up question after
that
sure there is no fiscal note on this
again the secretary of state may be able
to give you
additional information we have various
portals in the state of new hampshire
right now
being able to accept uh an
information uh it may be just a uh
an email that somebody sends uh you know
set up the portal
saying hey if you want to change to
election
uh you know your registration or
whatever
and it send an email to the appropriate
person
um so again whether or not
secretary of state filled out the form
and said that's the system that i'm
looking at
which would be in compliance with this
legislation
but it can be very simple
follow-up thank you my follow-up senator
is
um so you envision this
this is being a state-run portal uh
looks like being run by the secretary of
state's office
and would this be a standardized um
you know portal similar to the dmv that
tom clark's
access where it would be standard
basically standardized for all
time i see it being run by
doit but that doesn't necessarily mean
that that's what would happen
there are various portals that we have
out there right now
and that this would be an another one
added to
a bigger statewide portal that would
have if you want
you know a statement that says if you
want to change any of your voter
registration
or register to vote you know here's
where you start you click on it
uh put in your name and some basic
information what you want to change
i hit the send button and that email
goes to
the secretary of state to send out to
the appropriate
town clerk and again i don't see that
that would be
a large cost impact on the state
because we've already got similar things
set up
um but again i would defer to the
secretary of state
on how they answered the question when
they were asked if there was a physical
impact
further questions from committee members
on section part two
looking for hands uh senator gray i have
won
this section
is not a study committee
or a study with a report as to what to
be implemented
this actually says you're going to do it
um and so
if this act takes effect 60 days
we're april may we're probably talking
at a minimum the end of june beginning
in july
because we're not having session i don't
think till june so let's say the end of
june
we're talking effective 60 days after
its passage
earliest possible date august
and you were talking about
this being implemented when because you
have this
reference for until january 1st 2022.
and i asked this question because
i happen to recall that there's a big
push on
an audit going on for the secretary of
state this
summer i recall that they're looking at
ballot counting devices they know that's
coming up
so i'm sort of um
curious as to what you think the
timeline is and how
the office would handle it or would you
just prefer to
defer to the secretary of state's office
well
uh certainly the secretary of state
would add the final word
but the way i envisioned this the
it would be doit that would have the
bulk of the
effort here and they would be the ones
to make sure that the portal is in
aligned with others for security and for
the information provided
uh for you know doing the other things
they are currently
in charge of various portals out there
uh
and for those things and so for the
secretary of state just
to to get with them and say these are
the kind of
things that i would like on that
i think is a minimal intrusion on
secretary's
efforts if your committee decides that
you want to push one of those dates out
certainly we can talk about that in the
committee of conference
or if the committee in the senate
wants to accept it um i don't see that
it would be a big problem one way or the
other
thank you representative prudhommer
brian
representative prudhommer brian we're
having a very hard time hearing you
we've had that problem before i think it
has to do with the angle of whatever
device you're using and the microphone
no no better
do you have a volume on your computer or
device that might be turned right
way low
i'm going to go to representative grow
and we'll come back to you
representative prude homer brian
representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator gray for taking my question
senator gray would all of the proof of
identity and proof of
uh residency requirements that we
that we have in the law would that still
be in place will
will this portal in any way affect those
things
no it won't because what you're doing is
just starting the process for
voter registration or absentee ballot
those forms
as the rest of the state law stays
intact
it does not allow you to register it
allows you to request to be registered
and request to have an absentee ballot
and request to have your
your name party or whatever else uh
is and it would be up to the election
officials
still in state law as it is right now to
complete those
thank you further questions from
committee members representative
prudhomme o'brien you want to give it
another shot here
i'm not hearing anything
all right
anybody else on the committee on part
two
okay part three was recounts
i didn't see anything on that part four
had to do with the format
of statements being filed any questions
from committee members
and last part on the budget
any madam chair representative growing
i did have a question uh on on part
three
um senator gray
uh do you know how long the existing
uh recount fees have been in place and
what the cost of living increase has
been since
the current fees were enacted uh
no i don't um i can
see if i can quickly look up the statute
and tell you what it says at the bottom
for for when it was
um if you you have to bear with me
for me to do that though well we the
committee might be witnessing
a miracle senator gray thinks he's going
to find a statute that's
only got one date associated with it and
hasn't been mucked around with the led
by the legislature since its enactment
so let's see
660 uh cone two is what i'm looking for
so i'm on my way
i'm hitting the browse button
i'm going way down to the bottom
and 660
fees on two
i can tell you that the last time that
that statute was
uh uh amended was in 2008
and that uh before that um
before 2008 it was 1995
but i can't tell you which sections
as long as there's more than one date it
means you can't tell anything
all right okay thank you all right so
we're going to have to wait for that
miracle to occur on another day
committee members
all right um i am going to
go to we have three persons signed up to
speak on this
um and actually i'm looking for
senator khan is there somebody here for
the senator or senator khan
i'm not seeing anybody representative
lane
i just madam chair i just want to let
you know that i came in late
and that i'm at home uh alone in my
office
thank you very much for officially
joining us okay
is there anybody here for senator khan
i'm not seeing anybody raising their
hand jen am i do you see that i'm
missing anybody if you're there i don't
see anybody
i do not either all right thank you all
right cordell johnston
from new hampshire municipal association
has
also signed up to speak on this bill
good morning madam chair and committee
members cordell johnston representing
the new hampshire municipal association
and i'm speaking only on part five
if that's okay and uh we do support part
five
uh i think senator gray explained that
very well
uh but just briefly um as i think you
know
most towns have their town meeting in
march
and that's when they adopt their budget
and approve expenditures
but they they have a fiscal year that
runs on it on a calendar
calendar year basis so by the time they
actually adopt their budget
they're already two and a half months
into their fiscal year
so rsa 3213 authorizes them to spend
money during that first two and a half
months before they adopt the budget
um and
to to make expenditures that are
reasonable
uh compared to prior years
and as senator gray mentioned there are
some towns
that have a that have adopted
any town can do this but a small number
have done it have adopted a
june 30 fiscal year and if you have a
june 30 fiscal year
you can either have your town meeting in
march or have it in may
but in either in either case you're now
adopting your budget before your fiscal
year begins
so you don't so you don't need the
uh the benefit of rsa 3213
unless you find you find yourself in a
situation like what happened last year
when you have to postpone your meeting
as a number of towns did had to postpone
their meetings until
after june 30th and rsa 3213
did not apply to them so we had to get
the governor to issue an emergency order
which he did
that authorized those towns with the
with june 30 fiscal year to
get the benefit of rsa 3213. so this
part 5 would simply put that in place
permanently
in the event that there there's a
situation like that again
where those towns have to postpone their
meetings until
after june 30th so that's that's the
purpose of that
um madam chair you you raised a question
about
the about the apostrophe uh
in line five and um
that was a good question and it really
is
it's it's a matter of uh correct
english uh the problem with the existing
law
is it says prior year apostrophe
s so if you're intending to refer to
just last year it should say
the prior years but it doesn't have the
word v
in there and so you're left
it it's unclear whether whether the
statute
intends to refer to just the the last
year
or intends to refer to all prior years
and i'm not sure the answer i'm not sure
it matters that much but it
ought to be clear one way or the other
so it either should say
the prior year apostrophe s
or it should say prior years
apostrophe and this bill changes it to
say
prior year's apostrophe and
i do think that that's probably the
better answer
because if you're just comparing it to
last
year last year could have been an
unusual year
so for example if you look at a town's
election budget
in 2020 the town had probably four
elections
state pri presidential primary town
election
state primary state general election
in 2021 they only have one election the
town election
so your it i think it makes sense
that your election budget ought to be
or what you're spending on elections
ought to be based on
um sort of an average of some number of
prior years budgets rather than just on
last year's budget otherwise you could
be spending a lot more
if you had an unusual amount of
expenditures
last year so sorry to
sorry to go into such detail on that but
uh but the point is that the language in
on line five ought to be
cleaned up one way or the other it
should say
either the prior year apostrophe s or it
prior year's apostrophe
thank you
does anybody have any questions for
mr johnstone i do matter chair
uh thank you mr johnson uh
so you indicated you actually took a
position in part five does the
missile association take a position on
any other parts of this uh
legislation uh no no
well i do think that uh part one is a
useful clarification
um but uh other than that no we don't
have a position on anything else
thank you anybody else
all right i'm seeing nothing thank you
very much also
signed up to speak on this bill is
john atherton i don't see you in
attendance but if you
are if you could raise your hand that
would be terrific
and we will listen to your comments
i'm not seeing anything is there anybody
else in attendance who would like to
comment on
sb 83 deputy scanlan joins
us welcome
deputy are you with us thank you madam
chair i got uh
kicked out for a second now i'm back um
uh madam chair i'm david scanlan deputy
secretary of state
uh and just uh you know there were some
questions that were posed uh earlier
in the testimony i thought i would just
address those uh
as best i can i believe represent
bergeron
raises an interesting point with the
constitutional mention
of uh the role of moderators uh in the
constitution
uh you know i don't know that i'm
qualified to answer
you know giving a constitutional legal
opinion on exactly what that means
it's probably a good question to pose to
the attorney general's office
but what i can tell you is that this
provision in the statute has moved
around
over time uh you know relaxing the role
of
uh the moderator being able to process
uh
ballots that have been marked
by voters um and has tightened it up
so you know that part of it seems to be
the priority of
the legislature based on the you know
the feeling at the time
um and i'll just say this personally i'm
not speaking
on behalf of the office but but i
believe that
the moderator is elected by
the people uh in the town or city ward
to do a job you know based on their
integrity and credibility
and they should be permitted to do that
job it's for a fairly short
term and uh
you know if as long as they handle their
job
in a very objective professional way
it probably doesn't matter that they
might be running for some other
position on the ballot you know the same
is true with a town clerk
their supervisors have a checklist i
know that the legislature
is full of representatives who are also
moderators
and the ones that come quickly to mind
are representative lying
representative dan eaton uh represent
howard pearl representative bob harb
and and i'm sure that's probably just uh
the tip of the iceberg so you may want
to um
you know you may want to ask them for
their input on this
item as well you know i know there are a
number of uh supervisors of
the checklist um i believe
representative ward is one
and uh you know so i i think those
individuals may have some
important insight in helping you
decide that topic moving on to
part two the question was asked
is there a fiscal note uh to
creating an election information portal
uh the answer to that is yes uh we
haven't
figured it out yet uh what that would be
because um it really depends on the
design
um i'll start off by saying that that i
agree with the principles that
senator gray has put together in the
creation of an election information
portal
it may sound like a simple thing to do
but um
i.t projects usually end up
not being completed on time and i think
that the
uh implementation dates that are in here
are too ambitious
i think it would be more reasonable to
shoot for something for the 2024
election cycle and i say that because
not only
would we have to design and develop
the portal but we would also have to
come up with the procedures
on how the portal would interact with
local election officials whether it's
the clerk
or the supervisors of the checklist to
make sure that
the standards and the practices that are
being used are uniform
and and they're properly trained and
that would be a very important part
of this process we also do have some
other important
i.t projects that are underway that
that have a priority one of them is
moving forward with electronic poll
books
in a way that the towns can benefit from
them
uh we all know that the optical scan
accuvote
devices are really
rapidly approaching end of life and so
we are
actually looking for an alternative to
that
with rfps being issued and things like
so again yeah we believe this is a
direction that we want to go
election information portal but we want
to make sure that we do it right
and that we have enough time to do it
properly
madam share the only other area that i
would address
is part four
relative to the statements that are
filed by political committees and
candidates
uh senator gray uh is addressing
uh an important concern and that is that
uh we have many legislators that are
filing these reports now
on the online electronic system
that works great once the information is
in there
the information is in a searchable
database
so individuals that are interested in
different parts of
campaign finance reporting can go there
and see trends and see who's
contributing what to the candidates
but we do have a pretty significant
number of candidates
and candidates running for high offices
that file paper reports which is still
permissible
under the statute many times those
reports are hand written
and often times those are not legible
in terms of being able to easily read
the information that's being reported
sometimes we receive type documents in a
font size so
small that we literally need a
magnifying glass to be able to
read the content and those are very
difficult things to
put in pdf form on our website and
you know and have it readable to the
general public so
i think that the effort to standardize
the type of reporting and at a minimum
requiring that to
be legible and that there be a minimum
font size
that's required is really important to
uh transparency and disclosure and
so we think this part of the bill uh
is an important uh uh
it would just be important to the
process with that i would be happy to
answer any additional questions
questions from panelists
thank you oh this is the room yeah
representative
sorry guys thank you madam chair and
thank you thank you
take the
font size and different you know
standards
to do their reports uh in the
handwritten format
well that yeah that will be a
determination
by this committee and and your
current part in the senate um
you know the online uh campaign finance
system
uh is actually working quite well and
at some point uh it would uh
make sense to to certainly move in that
direction
when when we first started uh when that
was first created
there was uh significant concern that
you know there were a good number of
legislators that
you know didn't have access to laptops
and computers to keep spreadsheets
uh and things like that you know i i
think that is
um uh less of a argument uh to make
today
uh because uh you know everybody is
doing
things online you know these these
meetings are a good example of that
where you know we're just moving to
online
uh forums you know for having these
discussions so
the access to the technology uh i think
has dramatically improved
since we first implemented the the
online filing system
um at some point you may want to say you
know we'll
you know we'll start with the top tier
of candidates um
you know governor uh executive council
senate um and you know start there
making it a requirement
and then moving on to the house and the
county offices um
but again ultimately that you recall
representative barry yes deputy stanley
questions about the reporting side of it
and um this
is legible and as you are aware i'm
probably one of the most prolific
readers of campaign finance reports in
the state
um this is a real actual problem um
and you see these candidates for a major
office
through an including governor who filed
these reports
on paper and by the end and i used the
online system i'm the treasurer i think
for
three different uh committees um so i'm
a political user of the online system as
well it's incredibly easy to use
and i just have to wonder why why are
these campaigns which are sophisticated
raising more than five thousand dollars
why are they not using this online
system that's in my opinion
makes life easy it takes care of all the
weird nuances of campaign finance law
for you uh
richard barry i i would first of all
believe that you are a prolific reader
of
the information that's available in
those campaign finance reports
i you know i really don't want to
speculate on why a particular candidate
would not want to file it online but i
will just confirm that
you know there are there are quite a few
major candidates that continue to file
their reports uh on paper
i would call it not true follow-up
go ahead receive many requests for
people to refile um illegible paperwork
i i i i'm not questioning i completely
heard your question but
representative barry you're still
showing on my screen is muted and
there's a little
echo to you could gen could uh
all right so i'm i'm coming through the
uh
i'm coming through the room um
how many requests does your office
receive
for committees and campaigns to refile
paperwork
um it happens every election
uh you know i would have to go back and
find some examples for you
of what those look like and i'm happy to
do that um
you when we receive them we we put them
up online
um which is our practice
in the form that they received if we
receive some complaints about somebody
wanting to view it
in a readable form then we will reach
out and approach the candidate
and ask them um if they would
give us something that we can read this
yeah the provision that's being proposed
this bill uh would give us the authority
to require that
if we determine that something is
illegible
thank you further questions from
committee members
i'm seeing none thank you deputy scanlon
is that
concludes who i have signed up uh or who
the committee
wanted to ask questions for is there
anybody else in attendance
who would like to comment on hb 83
um liz tentarelli has raised her
hand and joins us now uh liz
good morning
you are with us liz if you want to
unmute
let's try again here we are there you
are thank you
thank you my name is liz tenterelli i'm
president of the league of women voters
of new hampshire
a non-partisan group that very much
would like
to see voter registration
and keeping track of voter registered
voter
minor changes such as addresses
put into the 21st century so i very much
thank
senator gray for his portal idea
we firmly support that the national
league also supports
moving towards online voter registration
and i realize this is not quite that but
it is a step in the right direction
and i firmly uh support
sb 83 because of that portal
section thank you very much thank you
any questions from ms genterelli
i'm not seeing any thank you for
speaking this morning is there anybody
else in attendance who would like to
comment
on sb 83
i'm not seeing anybody so i'm going to
close the public hearing
on sb 83 and
open the public hearing on sb 89
xb 89 is on the bus
senate legislation that comes to us
relative to election procedures
and registrars of probate
and senator gray is with us
this morning still i just saw you
somewhere
um and welcome again
thank you um my name is james gray
i'm a senator in district six which
is alton barnstead gilmanton farmington
new durham
and rochester here to present
another piece of omnibus legislation
senate bill
89 we'll go through the sections first
section
has to do with the city chief election
officer
the we believe that the
chief election officer in
any location here in new hampshire
should be a
new hampshire resident if not a resident
of the town or city
currently the
way that the towns are done for the city
excuse me the cities are done for the
city clerk
in most communities that is an appointed
position
and there is no residency requirements
there is a city in new hampshire right
now
whose city clerk is a resident of a
different state
this bill takes away no duties uh
the only thing it removes is a title
and in accordance with state law
at the polling place it's the moderator
who is in charge of the election
um so again
between secretary of state and myself
we've
attempted to do this a couple of
different times and
maybe this time we'll be be successful
we've changed it again
um you know to take into some of the
comments that we've gotten in the past
section two
prohibiting the taking a certain
photographs within the guardrail
the state law prohibited
any photographs within the uh guard
rails or taking a
photograph of ballots um
there was a successful court challenge
to that
uh saying that a person could take
a photograph of their own ballot
we believe that
that that could lead to people
having to vote the way
somebody wants and take a picture of the
ballot and turn it
into that person who's uh but this
deals more with just if i'm in there
and i take a picture of somebody
especially if we have a ballot
which is a two-sided ballot like we did
in the last election
and could be used in any election that
taking the photograph of someone else
could also take a
photograph of their ballot and with the
cameras that we have on all the phones
now
being very detailed
that that picture could be blown up to
to see what the
how the person voted along with other
considerations so
we would appreciate you looking at that
uh
section three allowing the opening of
absentee ballot
our envelopes and the processes
of absentee ballots
again this was very very very popular
with the election officials
uh in the last election it
allows a quicker process
on election day and what this uh section
is attempting to do
is separate the opening of the outer
envelopes
from the processing of the absentee
ballot
and there's a couple of reasons for that
right now the processing of the absentee
balance
uh if you go into the temporary
legislation that we put through would
only happen
on the friday saturday or monday um
half you know after you've printed the
the checklist
um and then um if a
person is found not to have signed the
affidavit
or there is some other irregularity in
that affidavit
uh many communities attempted to contact
the individual
uh so that they could and i'm going to
use the term that is
used in the in the lawsuit cure
the ballot or fix the problem
um there is nothing right now that
would preclude a person um
putting a ballot into an envelope not
supplied by the state
or or putting the inner envelope in a
an envelope not supplied by the state
and sending it
in my community when that has happened
uh that that
envelope is opened because they don't
know that a ballot is in there
and then once they realize that the
ballot is in there
it's either stapled or taped shut uh
and put in with the rest of the balance
for processing on election day
this works on that same principle
and the principle of allowing people to
cure
what it says is that the clerk
can open those envelopes after they
arrive
uh under certain conditions and uh
look at those signatures and if they are
not executed properly
uh contact the individuals
this uh the wording that you see in
front of you
right now i worked extensively with the
aclu so that they
understood what was going on and
did not object to the language at the
time
i don't know if they have formed a
different opinion now but at the time
this went through the senate they were
in agreement with the language
this would allow the
clerk also to open the envelope in the
presence of the voters so if the voter
came
with that sealed envelope to drop it off
at city hall
this would also say that the court could
open it at that time
look at the signatures give the example
of someone who was
heading off you know maybe they're a
a snowbird and they're going off to uh
to florida they're dropping off that
ballot as they're on their way out of
town
if the clerk is able to look at it at
that time
to make sure that there isn't a problem
with the signature of the way the
affidavit is filled out
or the agent of the person right now we
allow family members
caregivers etc to be designated
to be able to drop the ballot off uh but
other ones that came through the mail
there would be a
date and time that it would need to be
posted
so that people could observe uh the
opening of those ballots
moving on to the next section the
post-election audit
um windham you guys just got done
with uh processing the
senate bill 43 on windham
part of the problem with windham is that
the secretary of state and the attorney
general
did not see a way that we could open
those ballot boxes
to do additional investigation the way
that the law was written
and preserve a chain of custody etc
so this bill it started out with just
re-establishing the committee to look
into audit procedures for the
machine count towns but we've added
several sections in there
to make sure that the ballot law
commission
if they find that there is a significant
difference between the vote
announced election night and
any recount that was done
or that an audit
finds a significant difference between
the
announced vote and
the audit that was conducted or if there
is other creditable
creditable uh information that they have
that they may request that the
attorney general do an investigation it
also has
words in there for the attorney general
to make sure
that they are allowed to open up those
ballot boxes
uh during the investigation and
he doesn't need to wait for the ballot
law commission
should he have credible information uh
that there
was something that needs investigation
he could do it on his own authority
again so it tries to take those things
that people said are reasons why we
couldn't do windham right away
and take away those roadblocks and
barriers
to that and the last part
is the duties of register probate
since the time i was in the house
i have tried to work to reinstate some
of the duties for the register of
probate
um and let me give you an example why
um my son passed away
a year ago december my daughter-in-law
had to go through the probate process
my son did have a trust which most of
his assets were in
um but the attorney
just the attorney and and the fees for
the state
the bill was a thousand seven hundred
dollars
and the only things that weren't in the
trust
was one automobile and a small bank
account
now the attorney did modify the trust
document slightly
to take my son's name off and to to do
the other things
but even saying that that was half of
the cost
and i'll drop down to 800 for the
probate
portion of this is ridiculous
absolutely terrible the cost according
to
the information that was supplied
by the court system um
is about a average is around 170 to 180
dollars
per probate they also receive
between six and seven phone calls
per um
probate filing what this bill does is
puts back in the register of probate
not to be an advocate for anyone but to
help the people through the process
telling them this is where you go into
the electronic system
this is the kind of information that you
put into
block one block two this is the time
period that you should expect
for the assignment of the executor this
is the time period you have
to do the uh assets
the inventory and the things that should
be included in that
uh not giving them advice on
legal issues but giving them advice on
procedural issues
so some of the my republican brethren
uh looked at the twenty dollars
this bill says that there'll be an
additional fee
twenty dollars vice 800 dollars for the
attorney
um a small small fee to pay
i believe that many many more people
with a person who knows the system
and can help them navigate that system
that there will be many additional
people who would be
able to go through the probate process
um without the use of an attorney
and save themselves hundreds
of dollars and
the 20 will fund
the register of probate it is voluntary
the counties don't need to do this if
they don't choose to do it
but again i implore you
to to think about our constituents out
there
my next step in this is if i can prove
that
we are saving the court uh considerable
funds uh because of the
the questions and different things that
are going on
is trying to get them to reduce their
fees
for that 20 dollars which we are
adding in future legislation and on
coming years
so with that i'm open to questions
thank you senator gray committee members
um questions for senator gray
um let's try to go through it by section
just to
sort of see if we can go through it part
one
um in regards to the city chief election
officer um changing the reference
to clerk
representative bergeron thank you
madam chair uh senator gray
he hadn't really had any questions about
this section until you brought up
a situation in portsmouth where the city
clerk
isn't a resident of the city
when i first started at city clerk in
nashua i was a resident of hudson so i
suppose
a similar situation applies to me what
is it
you're trying to accomplish here in
regards to the portsmouth city clerk
and what effect is this going to have on
a city clerk who doesn't live
in his or her city that she works
the problem i had is more with someone
who doesn't even live in the same state
but city or state right now
it causes confusion between the
authority
of the moderator at the polling place
and the city
chief election official the city clerk
that comes into play in recounts
it comes into play when there is other
decisions to be made
the city clerk doesn't have a lot of
authority during the election
and as clear if you look at the
legislation
they are still in charge of any
non-legislative action
uh that's out there if they want to you
know have
um the posting of the various
documents done in a particular manner
here in rochester the the city clerk has
these
uh boards that
have all the postings again as long as
that goes along with the
the state law that's fine and
so those are the types of things that
are in there
but again it does cause conflicts
at certain times with the authority of
the moderator which is spelled out in
statute
uh for operating the polling place on
election day
further question madam chair
representative go ahead
um so in a situation
where a city clerk is perhaps training
and supervising
up to nine or 12 moderators
and you have someone new who's
interpreting
state law in a way that the city clerk
knows is incorrect
the city clerk will no longer have any
authority over that moderator to ensure
that that polling place is being
operated and run consistent with how
all the other polling places in the city
are being managed
i believe that your question doesn't
state the situation properly
that the moderator is in charge of that
polling place
that if any resident or any citizen
in new hampshire has a problem with a
moderator not
following state law that there is a
hotline that can be used during the
election that i know here in rochester
uh i have been called upon because i was
a moderator for
more than 20 years to sit down with
new moderators uh and even go to their
polling places
and help them during their first or
second election
so that there's many things out there
but
the city clerk
still has responsibilities in the
statute
uh and that if there is a disagreement
the proper place for that disagreement
uh to be adjudicated is through the
secretary of state's office
and if that is on election day the
hotline is available
thank you senator no further questions
on this section
further questions from committee members
on
section one
part two is in regards to photographs
questions from committee members
representative muirhood
i'm sorry madam chair i did not intend
to
raise my hand all right uh
representative mcdonald
thank you madam chairman and good
morning senator
uh you that just correctly everybody
else representative mcdonald are you
on mute on your computer it looks like
you are okay there is
just a big echo coming through in the
committee room today thank you go ahead
we can hear you
okay
senator you you quickly observed in your
testimony that just about everybody has
a cell phone right now
and the ability to take pictures and so
forth
uh i'm just concerned about the
enforcement of something like this given
the number of
people who go through there and who's
going to even notice half of them who do
this
certainly enforcement is always an issue
again my hope is that with posting this
um you know at the polling place
possibly
uh that it will self-police
itself in most cases um
again you know the enforcement may be
a person that takes a picture uh that
the moderator might just ask them
to delete that photo uh before they
transmit it to any place
but again what we're trying to do is
discourage the people not uh
you know have a confrontation with the
voter etc
but you know to set out in the statute
there is
a code that we believe that they should
adhere to for their behavior at the
polling place
and i believe that this even though it
may not
be easily enforceable that it will
tend to lessen the occurrence
thank you uh follow up madam chairman
follow up
um senator um just wondering have any
local election officials requested this
legislation or is it something
based on your own observations it was
requested by the secretary of state
thank you
representative o'brien
representative prudhomme o'brien i'm
hoping we've got the audi
bombs you can go ahead
can anybody else hear her
we're still having problems
again
if you representative o'brien if you've
got a question if you want to text it to
me
um i'd be happy to
ask it but we're still having problems
hearing you
you're it looks like you're muted on
your computer now let's give it one more
shot
all right try it again
yeah we're not yeah if there's something
it's not a new issue maybe we can do
something offline at some point with it
to see if we can get
your machine functioning with our zoom
is there anybody else
on the committee with the question in
regards to
part two okay moving on to part
three in regards to
opening envelopes and pre-processing
questions from committee members
i have a question man chair um
representative hamlet i'm going to
recognize first i
got saw her hand and then we'll go to
you representative teresa
okay thank you madam chair and thank you
senator gray for taking my question
so i have a i guess three questions
about
pre-processing um
in line 17 and 18
uh it says the town of city clerks uh
shall
open the outer envelope of all the
absentee ballots
received prior to 5 pm on the day prior
to election day so that
that just means they have to open
the outer envelope they don't have to um
no that just means that just means
they have to open the outer envelope at
some point they don't
have to open it on that they don't have
to open all the absentee ballots
the day before election day thanks
[Music]
the intent of the legislation is that
they would
on an ongoing basis opening those
open those outer envelopes inspect the
ballot
for the minimal things that you see in
the legislation
and then if there is a problem that is
identified try to contact the voter
through the information that's supplied
on the
voters absentee ballot request
which it does request information
such as the uh email number
or cell phone and then attempt to
accept that ballot uh right now
that if you
do state law without the exceptions that
we put in for the covid
uh back when i was a moderator if i
received a ballot
on election day uh from the clerk
uh opened that uh outer envelope two
hours
after the uh uh polls open
um then
notice that the affidavit wasn't signed
that really there wasn't any opportunity
for me to to accept that ballot
and i don't think that that's what is
intended
i think that if we can give the people
the opportunity
to get their ballot accepted
that that is what is desired
and this separating the
opening of the outer envelope from the
processing of the absentee ballots
allowing the clerk to do it actually
requiring the clerk to do it
ahead of time check those things and
if they have the information to contact
the voter
contact them is in the best interest of
the democratic process
okay my follow-up question so i do
understand your intent um
so in lines 24 and 25
um it does require the clerks to open
the outer envelope so there are actually
three steps there's the opening of the
outer envelope
the reviewing of the affidavit
and then the final processing which is
on election day
but the so they're allowed to open the
outer envelope
and review the affidavit and then if
there's
another pre-processing day with with a
team
of the election officials say on the
saturday before the election
they will have to go through that
process again with that ballot
and then mark the checklist
i did not touch the statute about the
what the moderator has to do in
processing an absentee ballot
and the reason i didn't touch that is
because of the court order
uh for in joining
the state from checking
signature verifications
now what the process would be
um is certainly the moderator would also
look at those signatures
uh to make sure that the affidavit was
filled out properly and that at that
time they would be allowed
to put the annotations aloud
onto the checklist therefore
allowing them to process the balance
more quickly on election day
from my many years as an election
official
moderator the only time i ever
had any difficulty at all uh was on a
presidential
election and then with proper planning
that too wasn't a problem i would hire
an extra individual or two
to assist me in that process and i was
always able to efficiently process those
balance
okay thank you for taking my question
representative terezian
thank you madam chair and thank you
again uh senator great for taking the
question
um much of my question was answered with
the last
question question to receive um
but the what i've got left i guess is uh
it appears that the you know there's a
two-fold
reason for uh wanting to count
or open the up ballot of st ballots
prior to
election day uh one is certainly
um posted free up time on election day
for town first and so forth
and the other two address um
some of the things you mentioned like uh
to cure any problems such as commitment
signature incorrect name and so forth
is there any data on what you know
to what extent that's a problem for
people forgetting to put that name or
sign
the uh the number
i do not have any factual data
um secretary of state may um
in the phone calls that the secretary of
state conducted
uh with the supervisors of the checklist
with the
town clerks and with the moderators
after the election it was a very very
very popular thing to do
i wanted to add that
one of the questions that the aclu asked
me
was whether or not there is a precursor
to reinstituting the signature
verification
and my answer to him was that if if i
were doing this
i would tell him right up front but
to reinstitute that signature
verification
uh requires a couple of different things
and that's
a method of cure which is the reason the
aclu
asked this this would be the method to
cure
but also would involve training provided
by the secretary of state
and a petition from the secretary of
state's office to the courts
to lift the injunction
go ahead further question thank you so i
hit this
under this provision if it would become
law there would be a
disadvantage for anybody who voted
absolutely ballot
uh when their ballot didn't get to the
top of to
let's say the night before election or
whenever the cutoff is the morning of
the election day
they that individual or individuals
wouldn't have the same
chance to have their
any deficiencies corrected
that is one of the issues that the aclu
discussed with me
but i assured them that you know if i'm
doing as much as i can to make sure that
that ballot is counted
and that they have fulfilled the process
there's nothing else i can do nothing
greater
and if i limit um you know that
only ballots can be opened at
two days before the election then i may
be taking
away the ability to cure from that
individual who dropped their ballot
off on their way to florida um
you know and and taking and depriving
them of their
right to franchise thank you
representative bergeron well thank you
ma'am chair
senator gray i too uh wanted to
address the language uh of line 17
and 18. uh am i clear then understanding
that it's your on page two
um it's your intent that this process
shall be conducted for every city town
and state election
uh in all cities and towns it's not a
local option
it's going to be mandated because it
says shell
the opening of the outer envelopes yes
it shall be done
and done by every city town village
district
etc yes the second part of that
and this is a concern because i think it
would be a logistical nightmare
you're saying that this needs to be done
on the day prior to election day as
opposed to
a day prior to election day and i'm just
thinking of a situation
in nashua where in a state general
election there are going to be thousands
of ballots
they're going to have to be opened and
examined
the clerk or someone in the office will
then have to follow up on a number of
those
trying to contact the voters and on that
same day
they're trying to set up the polling
places in in nine schools in the case of
nashua
i just don't see how this can physically
be done
was it your intent to say the day before
an election or a day before the election
uh again i'd have to go back you know
you didn't give me the page number so
i'm not quite sure which line
sixteen
uh the town of state clerk or their
destiny shall open the outer envelope of
all
absentee ballots received
prior to 5 pm on
the day prior to the election the
envelopes containing
all right the intent of that
is that this has been an ongoing process
from the first day that they have
allowed people to vote
absentee and that those ballots
maybe once a week during the first part
of it but
as we get closer to the election opened
on a
daily basis to make sure that they are
so that there isn't a
a bunch of ballots and remember a lot of
our absentee ballots as you
remember are people who vote right there
at the polls
and this again
would have the provision in there that
while you're still there at the poll
that whether you seal that outer
envelope or not i really don't care
but the clerk would be able to verify uh
your signature
on the affidavit so uh saying that there
will be a
ton of these things happening on
the day before the election is not
what the intent is the intent is that
this be
an ongoing process so that there isn't
a slew of these things happening on the
day before
and again all those people who voted in
person
you know it would be a much easier
process then because
you could just uh tell them not to seal
the outer envelope as
uh they would hand them back to the
clerk and would be good to go
representative bergeron i see your issue
in the wording of the statement it does
make it look like it's all supposed to
be done
then thank you madam karen and i and i
don't have any further questions
thank you any other committee members
with
questions on part three
of sb 89
i'm not seeing any part four regarding
the election audit counting device
committee questions from committee
members
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair uh
senator my question pertains to page 5
line
36 um all the other
sections of this bill
have an effective date of either a
specific date or 60 days after
passage this one says it's effective
upon passage
would this in any way undermine or
override what we did with senate bill 43
no um in fact i think that this supports
senate bill 43. if ins uh the
execution of the audit in windham uh you
find that there's a significant
difference
in the election for the governor or the
election for the u.s senator which you
included in your
[Music]
modification to the bill this would
allow
the secretary of i should say the
attorney general
to say do i need to expand the
investigation into other communities for
that
one or both of those elections and check
to see if there were
regulated therapies there which senate
bill 43 would not allow you to do
because it is specific to windom so
again if you think that
the ward 3 in manchester uh
also had a significant difference
statistically you know from the averages
of how they normally voted
and that was one that the attorney
general said well you know maybe we
ought to look at that
this bill would allow them to expand
that
in you know request uh let me stay
emphatically that i believe that what we
are actually going to find in windham
is that the hand count conducted at the
archives
lost control of one or more of the
ballot thank you senator gray we have a
process
established for sb3 and i really don't
want speculation
as to election results coming forward
um so um
representative bergeron for the question
no further questions thank you
thank you further questions from
committee members representative
muirhead
thank you madam chair um i wanted to
inquire about
the very beginning of this section
where the procedure for
populating the um the committee
is described at lines page 3 lines
30 to 30 4.
um i wonder if you considered
um a process that ensured bipartisan
representation on the committee
it seems plausible that or it seems
consistent with this process that the
committee might be populated by
entirely by members of one party
um let me go back and
look at it
two members of the senate and
then three members by the
speaker of the house that is normally
the standard language that we put in
uh generally what happens there is that
the
speaker of the house with that language
would appoint
um one member from each party and then
the third member
uh maybe whomever uh is chosen
in the senate when there's two members
uh generally that is
one member from each party but we
rely on the integrity of the two
individuals that are doing the
appointment
to make sure that there is bipartisan
representation on these type of
committees
follow up thank you madam chair would
you be willing to amend it to
to specify that expectation seems like a
very prudent
sensible expectation why not make it
explicit
this were will be legislating for for
posterity that may or may not remember
these conventions
uh again the bill is in the uh control
of the house
uh who are the ones who will make those
decisions
but if i'm using that logic
then i need to go into an awful lot of
bills that have
uh committees and put that same language
in
i don't believe that we've had a problem
in the past
in making sure that these type of
committees are bipartisan
and uh therefore i personally don't see
the need
thank you further questions from
committee members
we are talking about part
five excuse me part four
of the bill representative bergeron i'm
sorry i was uh my question was gonna be
on part five
i i i left before i looked
all right any further anybody else on
section four in the committee all right
moving
to part five questions from committee
members representative bergeron when we
started
and and again i withdraw my question i'm
sorry thank you
okay um
committee members questions on part five
representative mcdonald thank you madam
chairman
um and again good morning senator
um historically candidates for register
of probate
have often been party activists of
either political party
and sometimes they have probate
experience sometimes they have not
but when they come into the office it'd
always be a seasoned staff it usually be
a seasoned staff to back them up
that of course is no longer the case
given changes over the last decade uh do
you envision any kind of training or
or how would a party activist with no
probate experience
meet the responsibilities of the office
if they were elected into this
well i i point to other elected
officials that we have right now
um that the registered deeds
um oh the appointment of the
deputy register of deeds deputy register
probate or the finance
person in the county for the treasurer
and that the county commissioners
because they do
have the responsibility of making sure
that the services are provided
if they in conjunction with the county
convention
decides that they are going to have
these duties for the register of probate
and someone is elected
whom they feel is incapable of doing
those duties
uh they would also be able to uh um
take and elect a deputy or appoint
appointed deputy
to that person and through the use of
the
uh controlling the salary of
the register of probate and the
what would be the deputy i believe that
as in the past speaking historically
has happened many many times before that
those controls would be exercised by
those
county commissioners thank you
further questions from committee members
representative barry um yes so senator
great
a point has been made quite often by the
opponents of this provision
about experience and who we elect but to
my knowledge
and maybe you can confirm this for me
outside of county attorney we don't
require
experience for any other office to be
elected including state representative
governor executive council um the only
requirement
is age the exception of current attorney
so why
is there a provision in here that says
they have to be experienced or is it
just like
every other elected office like every
other election office and
sometimes i think people have told me
that
it's the ability to fog a mirror
further questions from panelists
representative barry you have any
follow-up okay
anybody else on the panel on section
five
or part five
representative lane yes thank you madam
chair
um i noticed that
uh there's a provision about the
archives putting things older than
i think it was anything older than 40
years
in the state archives as
that will make it very difficult for
people to conduct title
uh because they're going to have to go
to the county and then they're going to
have to go to the state archives or
anything that's older than 40.
is there some reason that that cutoff is
made and
and why we're doing that
the original cutoff in the original
legislation
was actually 35 years and at the
request of a couple of different people
including the
court system was changed to 40 years a
lot of the
research that is done is
actually only done back to 40 years
for the property records
and the availability at the the archives
um and if the secretary of state is
still on
i believe that their process is to
um take in and make these records
uh digitize them and make them available
so that it actually may be easier to
search the records that are
over 40 years old because they may be
able to do them from the comfort of
their own
living room and their lazy boy and
and be able to search them
electronically
okay thank you further from committee
members
we're on section five further questions
on any part of the bill before i open it
up to public comment
all right i'm not seeing any so at this
time i'm going to turn to my
sign up list on this bill and signed up
to speak on this
bill is speaker scitec
um
good morning we we're yep well good
afternoon yes we can
welcome good afternoon thank you madam
chairman and thank you members of the
committee
my name is donna scitec i am a former
registered probate
and have a long history with this
issue going back almost 40 years
in 1983 i was a member of judiciary
committee when we
unified the court system prior to that
the county was responsible for the
superior and probate courts
they were part of county government this
bill
tries to pull them back under the county
umbrella
and i'm opposed to part five of this
bill
because it doesn't make any sense
organizationally financially
or logistically it might have made sense
to have the
registered probate who served as the
clerk of the probate court
be part of county government when the
county was responsible for the probate
court the county had the courthouse the
county paid all the employees
during the unification of the court the
court system
the state took over those
responsibilities but they had to leave
the register
of probate the title and the duties
because it's mentioned in the
constitution so between 1983 and 2010
the register of probate was a full-time
job
with a full-time salary and a staff
that could help train anybody who was
elected who
may not have been aware of all the
duties of the office
in 2010 there was a court efficiency
committee i was a member of that
and the court looked at ways of
being more efficient in their operation
and customer service
and basically
improving the way they operated so they
did a lot of study about
how much time was spent answering the
phones going to the counter
and as a result of that they came in
with a
bill that passed in 2010 that
consolidated
the probate court the district court and
the family court
under the umbrella of the circuit court
they were left with the constitutional
office
of the register probate the
the bill in 2010 took the duties of the
registered probate
and gave them to a court appointed
uh clerk of the probate division of the
circuit court
but you're left with the title the
constitutional office of
the registered probate and the duties
they left for that
office were to be the record keeper of
where the documents were held
so they they were the keeper of the
historical documents and you can see
uh on uh page eight say uh
line line twelve the old language the
register probably
responsible for coordinating with the
secretary of state and the
administrative judge of the circuit
court
the preservation of any closed files
having potential for historical
significance and then you go down to
pick up on line 19 the register shall
maintain a current index describing the
location of any files
which have been removed from the core
section those were the only duties left
for the elected
register of probate i've i said
i think i could do that so i ran for
register of probate on a platform of
doing away with this
basically unnecessary position it would
require a constitutional amendment
the constitutional amendment did not
pass so the uh the office is still there
the duties are very limited in 2010 with
that
circuit court bill they said well gee
there's very few duties left we
but we have to uh maintain it because of
its constitutional
uh position and so they said the pay for
the the
registered probate will be 100 a year
that's paid for by the state
so this bill tries to pull them away
and pull them back into county
government where they haven't been for
almost 40 years
and the goal is to assist the parties
with their probate court filings
um and the the
the counties are given the authority to
set the salary for them and they don't
want the
county taxpayers to be on the hook so
they raised the
entry fees there is no fiscal note on
this bill
i don't know how much money it would
raise i'm told there are about 10
000 filings uh in probate court each
year so maybe there's a pot of 200 000
but without a fiscal note we don't know
that the
uh sponsor of the bill said he compared
it he says well
wouldn't you rather pay twenty dollars
than eight hundred dollars well this is
a twenty dollar surcharge on top
of the existing probate court fees which
are
maybe a hundred dollars or two hundred
dollars depending on what your issue is
um
so the registered probate would have the
duty to assist the parties and their
salary was set
be set by the county um
there's no provision in here that that
says that the
registered probe is going to have access
to any of the probate court information
there's no money in here for a computer
there's no money for a desk
it says they can be co-located at the
registry of deeds
okay if i am a person try struggling
with a probate matter
and i know that the register of probit
is supposed to help me where am i
supposed to find him
i don't think i'd look first in the
registry of deeds but
so finding the person having them have
the
access to the information that might be
helpful i i think is
is not just not going to work uh the
probate division if you look at the
court website
it has a robust website with detailed
instructions and information
and for people who don't have a computer
they do have a call center
where they all the calls for the whole
court system get picked up
at a call center and you can ask a
question about a case in superior court
you can ask about probate court
they have access to the information this
staff is trained
so having a elected registered probate
be responsible for something that's
already being covered
by trained personnel i think doesn't
make any sense
i hope that you will amend out part five
of this bill
and i would be happy to take any
questions you may have
thank you members of the committee who
have questions
i have a question madam chair
representative
and chair thank you madam speaker for
taking the question
just so uh i'm clear on this so each
county
currently has one register of probate
and they do no work
right 800 a year might correct them
that's right yes when i when i was
elected to register a probate i went
over to the
the courthouse uh the day i was sworn in
um and introduced myself they were nice
enough to give me a tour
and i didn't have to go back there or do
anything i i did not collect the hundred
dollars or during my campaign i said i
am not going to take money
for not doing anything that just
wouldn't be right so i didn't collect my
hundred dollars and i think some of the
other registers didn't either
but yes there's one in each county and
their only obligation is
as i pointed out is to coordinate with
the secretary of state and the
administrative judge
about where records are held and that's
done by staff
thank you representative cody
i did not have any questions i just
wanted to welcome the speaker
back to the committee i want to
acknowledge that representative cody was
there at the creation
he was there when we did unified court
back in 1983
where we think representative cody might
have been here when the building was
built he's been up here so long and i
don't mean that with any disrespect
i was there when the building was
remodeled for sure
there you go yes all right
uh further questions from committee
members
representative barry speaker you make
the point
in your statement that most of the
functions are done by professional staff
but as a counterpoint could i also say
that that is the case for most of
government
the governor does not the governor has a
policy director
the counselors have assistants that help
them most
work by government is in fact done by
professional staff is it not
that's right it's currently done by the
the court staff
and the the registered probate has no
interaction doesn't have a desk doesn't
when i campaigned i said you don't even
get a ballpoint pen
you have no connection
to the the court staff you're an elected
official and if you're part of
if you're going to be part of county
government they have even less
inclination
to uh include you
the sponsor of the bill talked about
because i wondered why the county
commissioners
would be appointing the deputy it to me
that that
seemed very strange and now i understand
that
he thought that the commissioners would
appoint somebody who had the
professional expertise
but to have that person be a part of
county government instead of being
part of the court system doesn't make
any sense to me
thank you further question from
committee members um i did
ask and send a invitation notice
to judiciary because of the nature of
the content of this bill
so i'm going to ask if there are any
members of judiciary with questions
representative horgan welcome
well thank you thank you very much madam
chair so um
we dealt with the probate registered
probate issue in the judiciary you were
on a
you're on the subcommittee together and
um so i i support
i support the basic concept of restoring
the registered probate i'm not sure if
this particular version
the bill is the one that i would want to
go forward i think
this this is a function that the
judiciary took over from the executive
branch
well i've been following this since 2009
it's been going on since
1983 and um so they they're doing a good
job
i mean this area is doing a good job of
serving the clients but i still think
they could do a better job of the
storage to register probate that's a
very very complicated uh
issue it would be analogous to the
registry of deeds we talked about the
fees for the
uh register of probate the uh i would
actually
favor continuing to support it through
fees just like judiciary does and the
registry of these
this is somewhat controversial but they
do charge fees which
actually make a surplus which goes back
to county government and i
i would not be against doing that for
the registers of probate um
speaker scitec even though she has a
different position
on this uh on this end than
um and i did she gave i think a very
good summary of the of the facts and the
long history of this so
um basically that free i think actually
we
eliminated the position in 2009 i think
was during the budget trailer but
2010 and 2009 that's about the same time
period um
and so that's i've been working on this
issue several times and uh
so that we have a constitutional office
that has few of any duties so they do
the state archives came in they do work
with the secretary of state's office
and the state archivist on preserving
the historical files which is uh
something that
um also the registry engaged preserving
their historical files we actually
passed a bill that expanded the duties
slightly so they can use the existing
funding that
state archives does the state archive
gets uh
has ample is has an ample uh ample
funding
through the various fees that it charges
to carry on its operations so they can
share a little bit with their registered
probate they can help the archives with
that
part of it so that's uh so that's uh
so space i do like the concept of part
five i'm not necessarily sure that i
would want to pass this exact version of
it and there's been several other
several attempts at working on this um
ever since we eliminated the duties of
registered probate they are by the way
currently they're elected by county but
they're currently state officials and so
far
they're officials at all so not actually
part of county government we would have
to
technically put them back in there and
they presumably would
need a staff and i guess staff like
everybody else
is uh hired by the county commissioners
after the county commissioners come in
and i've um
so i that's what i have to say about
that there's two other
topics are near and dear to my heart
that i've worked on over the years one
is uh
remember part two about taking uh photos
within the guardrail that's
uh kind of another attempt to get the
same goal as the infamous ballot selfie
bill
and i probably shouldn't admit this but
i was the prime sponsor of that
and uh that was a very strange thing
because
i don't think anybody until this came
along until
my bill was passed which actually made
it through the legislative process
pretty easily nobody
really thought of taking pictures of the
ballot and posting on facebook it wasn't
really a thing that many people wanted
to do
even though it was already illegal and
then we clarified the law suddenly
everybody wants suddenly this be came
with you there's a huge brouhaha over
and everybody wants to post their
ballots on facebook and uh
it's uh there's a federal court decision
so i
pretty much uh that's another i pretty
much like abandoned that effort i think
probably
probably retrospect i wish i hadn't
taken on that issue even though i think
the concerns behind it were right so
this is a
another way of doing it i think that's
uh what's in part two
um yes it's part two
yeah part two so part three i'm neutral
on i mean i'm
afraid to make any changes uh to
election procedures just after all the
turmoil of the last election
obviously anything that makes it more
complicated uh is
not good but it seems sensible i will
stay on
by representing stratfor county district
six the towns of durham and madbury
which is college town so i'm interested
i thought there's a little bit irony and
uh
irony that we're very concerned about
snowbird dropping off the absentee
ballot on their way
i guess to florida i guess you're going
to drop it off in november and the way
down to florida for the winter
and certainly they absolutely have the
right to vote here when we're not quite
as concerned about the rights of
people who spend the whole winter here
spend
um you know nine months out of the year
going to school but that's uh
that's i guess that's uh i'll just leave
it at that
and part one i think it's unnecessary
finally part three
i think we there are a lot of doubts
about the accuracy the voting machines
i'm certainly it was very
i was suspicious of the windham results
like even before there was the whole
uh controversy over them and
well i guess i don't want to speculate
about what happened i think actually
uh i think probably except to say i
think probably the original vote total
was probably
the correct one and that's still
speculation you told me you just didn't
want to do that
i just wanted to say that uh yes i trust
some machines but not 100
and certainly uh that uh committee and
the windham
it's not speculation say that people are
suspicious about the wind and results so
you know this reviving this committee
would be a good thing so that's
uh so basically i like part two i like
part four
i'm neutral in part three i'm opposed to
part one and i like the concept of part
five it's one of my favorite issues and
i was
thinking of introducing a bill in 2021
but i basically didn't do so
mostly just because uh the house is not
really operating at
full capacity so i was encouraged
by my caucus's leadership at least not
to introduce any bills that couldn't be
put off to 2022 or some other year so
that's why i decided to put that one
aside but i'm
not just pleased that senator gray
decided to go ahead and take another
try at it so um you know
probably so maybe we'll do some more
work on it this year
next year or maybe not so that's uh
that's my positions i'd be happy to take
any questions if anybody has any
thank you representative horrigan does
anybody have any questions for
representative horgan
i'm not seeing any thank you
representative and thank you for being
patient the next person
signed up to speak on this bill is kate
corgan kate joins us um
and i believe you should be with us
go ahead mrs horgan
good afternoon madam chair thank you for
hearing my testimony my name is kate
horgan i serve as the executive director
of the new hampshire association of
counties
the counties are weighing in on part
five which is the registers of probate
while we believe this bill is well
intentioned to assist members of the
public
uh this would put an additional burden
on county governments
uh these duties right now have been in
the judicial branch's jurisdiction for
quite some time and do not lie with
county government
if this bill were to pass while it does
cover
costs for the salary it would not cover
costs for
other things that would go along with
the office such as miles reimbursement
and office space any supplies that they
would need a telephone a computer
printer things like that um and our
other concern is if we
set a salary and the fees do not come in
as anticipated uh the county would then
have to make up that difference
uh that they have
while county governments understand that
this is an important
issue we have been greatly impacted by
covet 19
financially and adding this additional
burden at this time would be a challenge
i'm happy to answer any questions but i
wanted to keep it short since
speaker scitec covered most of the
points thank you and thank you for your
written testimony any questions from ms
morgan
from panelists committee members anybody
no thank you very much for joining us
this morning also
signed up to speak on this bill is kathy
stacy
uh thank you for joining us today
and i believe you should be with us if
not now
in a moment good morning can you hear me
we can
thank you wonderful good morning madam
chair
and members of the committee my name is
kathy stacy i'm the rockingham county
register of deeds the legislative chair
for the association of counties
and a licensed new hampshire attorney
i'm here
today to speak in opposition to senate
bill 89 part
five the registered probate proposal
now we ask that you remove part five of
the bill
and vote on it separately as an expedia
to legislate or strike it
entirely i'm not going to reiterate a
lot of the
i did submit my own testimony i'm not
going to reiterate a lot of the
information that
speaker scitec mentioned but
i'm going to tell you a few things there
was a representation made
uh that this is um
this proposal is actually
the counties can either opt in or opt
out and that is not true
this is an absolute the registered
probate
shall have an office either in the
registry of deeds or other location
determined by the county
so it is not optional at all that's the
first thing um
you know i would argue as an attorney
and as a
person who was in the courthouse that
the registered appropriate position
is a court function it is not a county
function
members of the public who come to the
courthouse looking for answers
are looking for answers at the probate
court they're not looking to be either
given
a business card or toll to go elsewhere
to
access information or assistance from a
registered probate
you know you we have already housed very
well versed staff at the court
the 10th circuit actually has a health
center that has been closed for years
and that help center used to be the
facility where the public could come
and a staff member would sit with them
and fill out documentation
so they did not have to use an attorney
so i mean
obviously the court got rid of that for
whatever reason we all know that they're
understaffed
but you know the concern is if i'm going
for probate matters i want to go to the
probate court
i don't want to search out someplace
else nor should i have to
um the issue with the 20 additional fee
um i recently filed a probate it was
a 250 dollar filing not 175
and that fee will still be in place and
on top of that an additional 20 dollar
fee
you know i i just find it
unrealistic to think that not knowing
how many people this is going to affect
how many people are going to be seeking
out the register of probate
to put on people's back to add another
twenty dollars to a fund
that only pays for salary doesn't pay
for any of the other responsibilities
as kate corgan you know noted and
you know basically we're talking about i
mean i can i can
assure you that i do more than um
fog up a mirror um which was said about
the
qualifications of people in elected
positions
and quite honestly if i i am very
fortunate as a
lot of other elected officials because
we have
at our fingertips
staff who are educated who help us
who guide us and that is the most
important thing
about this bill there is no
provision for that there's no provision
for education for whoever is going to be
the register of probate
to be knowledgeable and and explain to
people
the dynamics of what they need to do how
they need to do it
and in what order so you know that
that's a problem in and of itself
um the other thing i will tell you is i
am unaware of
any elected official who doesn't appoint
their own deputy the county
commissioners
have absolutely no say in the registered
deeds
my appointment of one or two deputies
i am required however to go to them to
get the person
bonded which has never been an issue but
the county commissioners
are not involved with that and i know in
this piece of legislation that's that's
one of the proposals is that
the commissioners are going to get
involved in appointing a
deputy you know why or how they're going
to figure out qualifications i really
don't know
the other thing that i'll point out is
this proposal uh references that the
registered probate salary
um is going to be consistent with rsa
548-17
that irsa says that the salary will be
100 dollars period
and then we go on later on this bill and
in
in we're suggesting that the county
delegation now is going to be setting
the salary so
a little bit of inconsistency there um
but you know all i would all i would say
and all i would ask
you to do is really take a look at this
i mean i don't know what the need is
that is is being
um proposed or being said is out there
it needs to be done but if there if
there is a need out there for the public
it falls upon the judiciary and it's the
judiciary who needs to staff their
offices and help the public that's why
we pay
fees to these offices
that's why people pay fees to my office
you know
we and by the way the fees associated
with my office have to do with
my relationship with department of
revenue because obviously
um we collect all the yell chip and the
transfer tax
but on top of that the recording fees
basically
um are used to help with the archival
um keeping of the records which is
substantial which is substantial
so you know in closing i would just you
know point out that
the counties are in opposition to this
bill and we
would appreciate your consideration
thank you
thank you any questions for ms stacy who
joins us here this afternoon we are
talking about
sb 89 representative barry
uh yes uh thank you um stacey for taking
my question
um you said in your closing argument
there
um basically you allude to the people's
attempt to seek
redress right if they have a problem
with the current probate
they have to go to the judiciary and
this is one of my issues
with the current system the judiciary by
design
is to be insulated from the political
will of people
it is supposed to be by design
independent
how so if a person is having an issue
with this body
how do they currently seek redress with
a body that is literally designed to not
be moved
versus if it goes back to the power of
people or accounting or elected office
we can hold that person accountable if
you don't do your jobs register of deeds
the good people of rockman county cannot
elect you but you do your job well so
they continue to elect you
so how do you reconcile that how do they
actually redress
when they really have no option because
it's currently being managed by a branch
of government
that is designed to not be moved well i
disagree with that
i i honestly believe that your position
is the answer to that
if you have members of the public for
your constituents who are having issues
with the judiciary
they come to you and ask you to put
through a piece of legislation
ask you to fund them you know all those
type of things through the budget well
however it has to be
i mean obviously you know even in this
bill there is an
option here to get rid of the registered
probate if they're not fulfilling the
functions of their position just like
there is for me and it isn't
has has nothing to do with an election
but the issue here is the judiciary and
the only people who can change that
is you
representative barry follow up to my
last question to your point
mr stacy isn't that what this
legislation is
isn't that us doing our job right now i
disagree
i think that you have a court function
that needs to remain in the court
it is not a county function it belongs
in the court
that office belongs to it needs to be
located within that court
not not the county not at some other
location where the people aren't going
to find it
because all i could think of quite
honestly is if i'm a member of the
public
who knows nothing about probate and goes
to the court because that's where the
court
the probate court is located and starts
asking questions and i'm given a
business card and said and told
yeah you can call the register probate
because it's his job
to walk you through the system but he's
not located here he's located let's say
in
portsmouth and i just drove from let's
say
londonderry i'm not going to be a happy
constituent
thank you representative mcdonald thank
you madam chairman
um mr stacy um you've obviously been
involved with this issue for a long time
i
i come from rockingham county you've
been registered
there for many years as you point out to
an extensive legal background as an
attorney
having followed this issue over the
years you have any insight as to how
well the
current situation has worked with the
clerk of court replacing the registered
probate's functions
what i will say is this my office
fields a lot of questions from members
of the public because they don't get
their answers upstairs they come down to
the registry of deeds
looking for help and guidance and and my
staff and i can't
help them um obviously we had clerks
that were there who were well-versed
they were upstairs in the court so that
when people came they could ask them
questions and they got their questions
answered
on site there at the clerk's office that
isn't happening as much now
and obviously now with culvert it's not
happening at all
right thank you
further questions from committee members
thank you very much ms stacy for joining
us and thank you for your written
testimony that we received
thank you madam chair the next person
signed up to
to speak is kelly monahan i'm not sure
i saw miss monahan in
attendance is would that be you deeds
i'm going to promote a raised hand
up that's anna tilton um miss tilton
you're also signed up to speak so you
join us
now and welcome
i get miss tilton
i th you should be with us i'm looking
for you on my screen
it looks like she's still in attendees
oh sorry
thought i promoted her there you go
ms tilton you should be with us if you
unmute you join us this afternoon on
hb89
okay we can
good so uh many of the prior speakers
have covered many of the positions
that i was going to address but i was
the register of probate when the
position was eliminated
and one of the one of the unfortunate
results of that position being away
is there's no long advocate for those
people who are coming to the court who
need assistance
but i had a professional staff and
together
we could provide services as kathy stacy
said there used to be a help desk to
assist people many of the public
um their ability to read
and understand the forms how to fill out
the forms
it's a problem but if if you
don't have a professional staff to work
with
it isn't going to be feasible to have
somebody sitting in some other office
who cannot provide legal advice
and may or may not know anything about
the probate process the court has an
entire staff available
to assist the public and any public
agency whether it's the
whether it's the court system whether
it's the dmv whether it's the registry
of deeds
whether it's the governor's office their
role
is service to the public and the
judicial branch should provide
at the minimum a help desk and eliminate
i i have uh heard complain
about the emailing everything has to be
filed in concord you cannot go to the
local probate court
and hand them a piece of paper it has to
be in through the e-filing system
and that requires the attorneys because
it's a complicated
not user-friendly system you know if you
want to
help the public reform the whole
process of how you work through the
probate system
let them record that paper in this
legislation it says the index
is going to be uh with this person
and the index needs to be in the court
because the court system has to be able
to find records
and the index is the only place they can
go to
to be able to find records um
the archives are at the state archives
they're turning to dust in in a lot of
cases because very few of the records of
the probate court have been digitized
i think that's a far more important um
far more to determine get done
rather than trying to put back
miss tilton if you could speak up we do
seem to have a bad connection i don't
know whether other
members are having a hard time hearing
i'm seeing some nods
so just please speak up thank you
okay um so in any case
the deputy register pay i don't know why
the county would be responsible for that
and i don't know if it says your payment
to the counties would be limited to the
other funds are available
um so it is not enough revenue
coming in through the recording fees the
county would be on the hook for these
for the salary and it's it's a complete
unknown how many
how many uh profit would be
filed in any year in any case i i
i i agree with kathy stacy and the other
speakers i think part five should be
broken out and ipl so thank you for your
time
and i'll take any question any questions
for miss tilton
i'm not seeing any questions thank you
for joining us today
also signed up to speak on this bill
is jane
bradstreet um
you should be with us i believe so
welcome you are miss bradstreet if you
unmute yourself i think you'll be with
us
yes okay we can
thank you very much my whole screen went
to flewy and i can't see any of you but
i don't think you can see me either so
that's okay thank you madam chair and
committee members for allowing me to
speak
i am jane bradstreet i am the merrimack
county register of probate
um and i would like to speak in
uh favor of this bill i have been in
touch with
eight other registers who are also
looking uh forward to what this bill
could
provide for their constituents
i sent some uh written testimony so i i
won't go through at all um
but there are two major problems with
what happened in 2011
which reduced not only the duties of the
probate
register but reduce the probate court
to non-existent i mean it is now a
probate division
underneath uh the circuit court um
and um a a court that
had a staff of around 53 uh people
across the state
um by my 2017 had about
nine people across the state um
and so the the first problem i see
is in the keeping of the historic record
when they talk about the historic
documents
it the registry of deeds and the
registry probate
go hand in hand to prove all the
ownership of property
in all the counties it's a very
important record
and it has it
really deserves a better oversight the
second problem i see
is certainly a customer service issue
though here in new hampshire we have
what we
term supervised probate which is a
little more difficult than
say our neighbors in maine that have
unsupervised probate
it is a little it's more difficult and
um
and the folks who have to use it
um could use all the help they could get
um large estates usually have attorneys
that help
its uh the smaller estates that people
do on their own that could really use
the help and
used to get the help but they no longer
they no longer do um
i was also the uh manager of the
information
center the creator and manager of the
information center
for the circuit court and we did try
very hard to
train people to be able to answer the
questions
of the probate court but there's a
there's a big difference between
district
court issues and and
probate issues you know probate is all
civil um people come to the probate use
the probate
procedures um when their family is in
some sort of crisis
they've lost a loved one or they need a
loved one to
come under go under guardianship and all
of those
are are sensitive issues and
now if you have a probate issue and you
can't handle the computer and you go to
the courthouse the circuit court
house you you go to the window and they
say oh there's a kiosk computer over
there
in the lobby that you can use
um to file your case and oh yes there's
a binder there that'll give you some
information
and there's a telephone if you have more
information call the 855 number
and they'll help you and that's about
all you get
if you're going if you're going
um to get help at the courthouse
um so this bill is i think an attempt
um to help the difficulties
to to throw the throw
some little help to the to the
constituents who
who need it at their times of crisis
um the training issue that's been
brought up is a critical issue i
i agree with it um uh
and i and i did try and talk with the
court about that
when we were talking about this um this
bill
and they um would didn't want to
provide any um and um
i would suggest that i think that we
we would work on that as registers
i certainly have 20 plus years
of experience in the probate court and
would
certainly be willing to be of assistance
in training other registers
i think having the register of probate
in fact i've talked to people who've
looked on the county
uh website um looking for probate
and i think for the register of probate
to be on the county website
would be a a good thing for
them to be able to find us and us to be
able to help
be helpful to people
just one last thing when we were when um
when senator gray was talking about a
case that
that he knew that somebody had had
that had an attorney that helped them
they
only had to transfer a car well
i think that if they had talked to the
registered probate they would know that
they could just go to the
department of the registry to
change a private car ownership
of one private car without
even going to the probate court so
that's an example of
what kind of help the probate register
could do
um if they you know if they have
a better profile um out in the public
and certainly they would deserve to be
paid more than a hundred dollars a year
um
for the work that they do and for uh
the training that they would have to
get to um to be able to do the job
and i certainly am willing to take any
questions anyone has
thank you very much ms bradstreet is
anybody have any questions for jane
bradstreet who appears before us
representative hamlet
right you're muted okay
thank you madam chair and thank you ms
bradstreet for taking my question
so how could you help the citizens if
the records are over at the courthouse
well we i had hoped that we would be
able to get
access to the the the database
you know all all of the estate um
records now are are electronic
um you don't file any paper anymore
they're all electronic
and it's all done in concord which is
one of the reasons the
the county court houses don't have any
information because
everything's done in in concord
but i think you can
the register can pick up the phone and
call the 855 number and
know the questions to ask and to get the
information that the person's looking
for
further questions from anybody from this
broad street the
representative hamlet follow up
oh well uh yes i thought i
had heard that the all the records are
not digitized yet
oh they they are not
they are not you would have to go at um
i
i was the one that suggested that the
the number of years be increased to
40 years that are of of paper
goes back 40 years at the courthouse but
you know i i
forget exactly 2016 perhaps
maybe it was 15 that the states started
all going
electronically so there won't
you know eventually here there's not
going to be paper there but
40 years is about as far back as the the
title searchers like to get to be able
to give someone a warranty deed
um sometimes there are unique situations
but
um the register ought to be able to
go into the courthouse and look at the
look at the paper files
they um that's one thing that
the register hasn't been even allowed in
to be able to do their job you know it's
the job that they have right now they're
not allowed to do because the court has
not is not cooperative with them
okay thank you very much
representative to rosian is that you i
thank you madam chair thank you
uh mrs bradshaw congratulating my
question
uh so today under the uh living under
the
don uh from the change that was adopted
in 2011
to transfer basically all the activity
to circuit court
what is your job description as a
registered probate
well just what they've just what they've
mentioned in the
in the bill as the keeper of
of any possible historic records
um to oversee it
with supervision from the administrative
judge of the circuit court
which is unusual for an elected official
to be supervised by an appointed
official but that's what the description
has been
and however we haven't really been
allowed to do that
uh we haven't been allowed in the in the
courthouses
to even see what's happening
follow-up question madam chair i'll
follow-up representative
thank you and thanks again for the
question um
propose legislation
i would that um better serve
users of the probate system
well i think they get a they get an
advocate that knows the system
and um and can can help them
negotiate their way through it by
knowing the
process and the procedures um
that they that they need to use to be
able to more efficiently use the court
and and get what they need and and have
somebody there
who's willing to be helpful i i
said before that the
uh the atmosphere of a district court is
very different than the atmosphere the
probate court used to be
and i think the circuit court has taken
the atmosphere of the district court
because the district court
is the 800 pound gorilla in the middle
of the table
because they it is the a huge bulk of
the court's
work and civil
cases are
that are in the probate court are much
more family
related issues
they're just a process people have to go
to to get the documents they need
to be able to process a person's estate
or
to be able to uh handle an incapacitated
relative
so um it's a it's
it's a different it's a different
culture
further questions for miss bradstreet
representative derozan did you have a
follow-up
yes thank you madam chair i went one
last follow-up
um so if this legislation would become
law
um do you think it would speed up the
process
of people going through the probate
from how it's currently done there are
there are certain time frames that are
important in probate
that you can't necessarily speed up um
but
i think it would i think it would help
um
our our constituents um get what they
need
and uh without a lot of um
difficulty and it certainly would make
the whole experience a better experience
for those folks who but through no fault
of their own
um have had to have to deal with the
with the
with the court system thank you
further questions for ms bradstreet
i'm seeing none thank you very much for
joining us um that concludes the people
who have signed up to speak on this
however also
attending and wishing to speak on this
is
dan healy um mr healey
thank you for joining us um
and did you have want to speak to
each s espy 89
yes derry town clerk
um i spoke on this bill when it was in
the senate
um my concern on this is part three
number two the opening of absentee
ballot outer envelopes
i had suggested that it be an
option for town and city clerks to
change the shell to a may
i don't think this bill takes into
account the larger town
the day before the general election we
had
around 500 absentee ballots returned to
us either done
in the lobby or coming through the mail
now it's saying that we would have to
then open up all those envelopes
the day before and verify the signatures
are there verify that they did develop
correctly
we did pre-processing we pre-processed
between four to five thousand ballots i
think
the pre-processing is a is a great
option and it does catch a lot of those
things
the closer you get to the election day
the clerks just don't in bigger towns we
just don't really have the time to
to do this additional step uh if we had
to open 500
ballots the day before i don't know how
long we would be in the office
and we still have to set up the polling
place my other concern with that
that section is the security of those
open ballots now
there's nothing in this bill that says
what we do with that box of
ballots that have the outer envelope now
opened
so i i think it needs some work on just
that section
and it really ultimately is the
moderator that verifies the absentee
ballots i know my moderator has some
concerns on that uh she
had told me that she submitted written
testimony
and i believe it addresses that concern
that it it's the moderators
responsibility
not the clerk and just the time
constraints on it for for the larger
talents
i think smaller towns might be able to
you know
they get say 50 ballots back that day
they might be able to go through them
but if you're talking
you know nashua derry manchester the the
larger towns
uh we we would have an issue going
through
500 ballots a day before the election
and contacting all those people um and
that ends uh my testimony i'd be open to
any questions
thank you does anybody have any
questions for mr
i have a question manager representative
thank you madam chair thank you mr
healey for taking the question
um pre-prove it uh when
you had to come or do all the processing
on election day was that a problem for
your talent did that work out okay that
way
pre-kobit we had uh no problem going
through the absentee ballots
um compared to 2016
i believe our numbers for absentee for
the general election were about 1200
ballots
uh this year uh we were closer to 7 000.
so there was a quite a big difference i
do think the absentee ballots with the
pre-processing
and depending on if um some of the laws
on
who can request an absentee ballot
change to to make it a little more open
we'd see probably in between the the
twelve hundred to seven thousand so
probably in that three to four thousand
range i'm assuming thank you very much
further questions for mr healey
i'm not seeing any thank you mr healey
asking i just lost somebody
where did they go um
margaret brines would like to speak in
connection with this bill
um miss brines welcome you should be
with us
you are if you want you we're all set
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
um briefly i'm margaret burns i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
municipal association and we are here to
express our support
for part three of senate bill 89 we do
not have any position on
any of the other sections generally we
support
this part of senate bill 89 because it
does provide
some efficiency for municipal officials
by allowing for a certain level of
pre-processing to occur
prior to election day speeding up the
process
on election day although i do recognize
dan healy's concerns expressed about it
being
a mandate for the opening to occur prior
to election day but generally
at nhma we have heard support for
some level of pre-processing to be
authorized so that the process can be
sped up
on election day we do have one
suggested amendment to the bill which i
believe
has been conveyed to senator gray as
well
on page three of the bill lines
21 through 23
the language in the bill right now says
that the moderator
shall mark the checklist so this is
talking about
the processing that is now that is
occurring on election day it says the
moderator shall mark the checklist
but we would recommend that the language
be changed to
the moderator or the moderators designee
and the reason for this is that because
in in practice it's not the moderator
marking the checklist it's the moderator
opening the inner
envelope announcing the name waiting for
the challenge and
a ballot clerk is usually there with the
checklist
actually making the marks on the
checklist so we
would suggest that the language be
altered so that the moderator can
designate someone
usually a ballot clerk to be the one
making
the mark on the checklist on election
day so
that concludes my testimony i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you any questions for ms burns
from
nhma
i'm not seeing any thank you um
also with us on um
this issue is deputy scanlon
deputy scanlon did you want to comment
on hb-89
thank you madam chair and uh once again
i'm david scanlan deputy secretary of
state
and i'll be brief because i know i'm
probably the one that's standing between
the committee at lunch
and uh we don't want that so um
i just wanted to comment on part three
um you know i i agree
with uh the comments made by dan healey
and margaret burns
um you know i will say that the
experience that we had
in the 2020 state elections uh relative
to the pre-processing of
absentee ballots was was very favorable
and
i think the the moderators in particular
found it to be a useful tool
in being able to efficiently process
their absentee ballots
um you know the one thing that's missing
in this language is
is the procedure
that took place in 2020 and that is
specifically
allowing the pre-processing to take
place on the thursday friday saturday
and monday prior to the election at the
discretion of
the moderator the other important
uh event that we found in this process
was the ability of
the clerks to contact the voters to have
them cure
deficiencies on the affidavit form
allowing those voters
to actually have their vote count by
being contacted
and coming in to uh you know to correct
the
the issue whether it was a signature
that was required
or some other thing and you know i think
that it's important that that be allowed
to continue
if it is done it should be uniform
across the state
all towns should have to follow through
on that
um but to the extent that the voters are
willing to provide the contact
information
on their application and that is either
providing a phone number
or a an email so that they can be
contacted
um the other uh section of bill that i
wanted to address was
part four um and that's dealing with
the audit after an election
and potential investigations
i know that this committee has has
re-referred
other bills dealing with the same
subject matter and i would suggest that
that this topic be studied along with
those other
items um you know the first part of this
calls for study committee but the
the later parts of it call for processes
that would lead to investigations
authorized by the bylaw commission or
the attorney general's office
i think we have to be very careful here
in terms of the processes that we might
put in place after an election
i think it's really important that we
have processes in place
that lead to accurate counts um both
at the local level and at the recount
and a process to audit the devices that
are used to count the ballots
uh because um
at some point we need to achieve
finality in elections that's just a
a really important component of the
election process
and not have uh questions
and not have uh elections questioned
ongoing after the fact and and after
the the count the recount and appeal
process have been completed
and i think that there's a door open in
this language to continue that
into the future um and
you know i think that that has to be
careful carefully thought out and
reviewed
and understood before we create a
process like that
and i'll in there madam chair be happy
to answer questions uh
on the bill um otherwise i'm ready for
launch too
thank you questions from committee
members for deputy scanlon
yes madam chair representative
again madam chairman thank you deputy in
regard to section 3 uh deputy
regard to pre-processing uh i'll ask you
the same question i asked the
prime sponsor um does the
secretary of state talk 70 data on on
percentage or numbers statewide of uh
absentee ballots where you know
signatures or
incorrect uh name were on the inner
ballot that caused that vote not to be
counted
yeah that and that's a great question
represents rosie and i don't have
any numbers at my fingertips but let me
see what i can pull together
this afternoon that might be helpful for
the committee that would be great thank
you
further questions from committee members
for deputy scanlon
i am not seeing any
either by raised hand or on my screen
thank you very much for joining us
thank you is there anyone else in
attendance who'd like to
comment on each senate bill sorry i keep
going back to hb
sb 89
raise your hand i'm not seeing
anything so at this time i'd like to cl
i'm going to close the public hearing on
sb89
i want to thank everybody for their
attendance today their patience this was
really not
two bills it was nine or 10 bills so
thank you everybody for joining us today
and at this point the the election law
committee of the new hampshire house
is concluded have a great day and nice
weekend everybody bye